عبر البحر الادرياتيكي من اليونان الى
ميناء باري جنوبيه ايطاليا واحد من عده
طرق للعبارات يستخدمه المهاجرون واللاجئون
من دول مثل العراق وسوريا وافغانستان
الذين يخاطرنا بحياتهم مختبئين في مقصورات
علمتني شاحنات العبور من الموانئ
اليونانيه الى الايطاليه قد يستغرق ما بين
تسع ساعات و30 ساعه
بعضهم يموتون اثناء محاوله العبور واخرون
يكشف امرهم ويسلمون الى الشرطه الايطاليه
في النور
العباره اصيب احد الاشخاص بنوبه ساره ولما
نقول انه تم جره وركله من قبل الطاقم
اخبرتنا احدى النساء عن عمليات تفتيشائره
تم 8 زعم انه لا يتم توفير المترجمين في
كثير من الاحيان وان بعض الاشخاص يمنعون
من طلب اللجوء قبل اعادتهم الى اليونان
يجري احتجازهم في السفينه التي وصلوا بها
بعضهم ترك اثرا على وجودهم هنا بكتابات
على الجدران هذا الرجل التقط صوره لنفسه
فيما يؤمن العام الماضي مقيد اليدين الى
قضبان حديديه علمتني عباره متجهه الى
اليونان ووفقا لروايته فان غرفه الاحتجاج
تقع في مكان مخصص للسيارات اسفل سطح
السفينه في ميناء بتراس اليوناني التقينا
بالوش من افغانستان تبدو قصتهم مثيره
للاهتمام حيث تظهر وثائقه انه في السابعه
عشره من العمر
تحت الشاحنه تبريد ومن غادرت السفينه
اكتشف امر وقتلت لم يستجيبوني بشان طلب
اللجوء ولم ياخ بصماتي بالاحتجزوني في
غرفه صغيره ثم اعاعدوني الى اليونان
من غير المعتاد ان تحتوي العبارات
التجاريه على غرفه صغيره محكمه الاغلاق
باقفال بهدف احتجاج من يوصفون بالركاب
المشاغبين على سبيل المثال في هذه العباره
وجدنا غرفه احتجاز يطلق الطاقه عليها اسم
السجن
احاول الاقتراب من المكان المخصص للسيارات
علمتني هذه العباره التي تتنقل بين
الميناء باري الايطالي وباتريس وايجونتسى
في اليونان
اماميه الان ما يشبه الصندوقا معدنيا قد
يبدو عاديه الى ان تنظر الى الداخل لا
يوجد داخله سوان ملاءه وقطع من الورق
المقوى على الارض الكلمات المكتوبه على
الجدار باللغه الكرديه لكنها غير مقروءه
ردا على تحقيقنا قالت الشركه الملكه
للعباره انها تلتزم بشكل تام بالقانون
الوطني والدولي واكدت ان افعالا وسلوكيات
وممارسات مثل هذا لم تحدث بتتنا على متن
اي من سفنها وحين واجهناه بما لدينا من
ادله نفى رئيس شرطه المحلي في باري اي
تواطئ من الجانب الايطالي
صوره ذلك الشخص مكمل اليدين لكنني لا اعرف
السياق او مكان حدوث ذلك
يخبرني زميلي ان الشرطه لا تصعد حتى على
السفينه نحن نسلم المهاجر الى طاقم
العباره وهم يسلمونه الى القبطان
هناك اعتراف ضمني اذا بان عمليه الاعاده
القسريه تحدث بالفعل والدفاع عن هذه
الافعال لا يقنع النشطى الحقوقيين
سلطه
انا متاكده ان الشرطه
وكذلك شرطه الحدود فما يحدث يتم من قبل او
امام شرطه الايطاليه نحن لا نستنكر فقط
كون عمليات اعاده طالب اللجوء هذه غير
مشروعه ولكن ايضا انها تتم بدون اجراءات
رسميه دون اي توثيق لما يحدث في الواقعه
من المستحيل معرفه الارقام الرسميه
عام 2014 وجدت المحكمه الاوروبيه لحقوق
الانسان ان ايطاليا احتجزت بشكل غير
قانوني واعادت 35 طالب لجوء على متن عباره
الى اليونان منذ ذلك الحين تصر الحكومه
الايطاليه على ان هذه الممارسات لم تعد
قائمه رغم ذلك سمعنا خلال تحقيقنا الى
شهادات ثمانيه اشخاص اعيد قصرا من ايطاليا
الى اليونان خلال الاثنى عشر شهرا ماضيه
فقط